the war in Syria has claimed well over
100,000 lives many victims have been
buried in mass graves as in so many
other conflicts the International
Commission for missing people works to
locate and identify those missing as a
result of armed conflicts and human
rights violations the organization says
there are currently millions of people
who've been reported missing or
disappeared across the world it's hoping
to raise awareness about the issue at a
three day conference in The Hague so
it's high time that the international
community and ICP can be that mechanism
takes note of this and begins to develop
an agenda to address these cases to
ensure that there is an international
mechanism in place to tabulate the
numbers of persons that go missing every
year and to develop capacities to
finally find people the icmp was
established in 1996 after the wars in
the former Yugoslavia its specialists
were able to identify ninety percent of
the dead found in the mass graves of
Schreiber neatza bringing some relief to
the relatives of the victims not cheap I
tried to find out the truth but it was
hard thanks to the ICMP I found the
remains of my husband and 22 family
members who were buried in seven Itza
after the genocide Alicia caused my son
my brother my sister they were all
killed thanks to the ICMP my loved ones
have a name again my ancestor my the
Commission has also identified victims
after natural disasters like the tsunami
in Thailand
you